so what they're doing is uh they
basically take like a vacant property
same thing as a spirit store they take a
vacant property they say hey we'll cut
you a check for 10 15 grand if we can
use your house right or they'll they'll
rent a property or they'll find a vacant
property and they basically just use it
for the month they have this operational
thing where they can just spin up the
haunted house and then they charge like
40 bucks you know to enter and you can
sort of do the math and realize man
they're probably making half a million
to a million dollars in about a about a
month
[Music]
all right you want to go with Rahul or
if you want to come out
all right troll of the year we haven't
even done our my our Millie awards for
the end of the year thing that we always
do
I'm calling it now the troll of the Year
give the background so Elon takes over
Twitter I guess the purchase went
through I feel like there was never like
confirmation like he actually wired them
on he just literally showed up the
office and like yeah there there hasn't
been like a proper ribber ribbing
ribbing ribbon-cutting moment like it's
not like a squatter you just like went
into the office and they're like I guess
you own it now oh you seem to be here
right yeah that's mine
the playground rules like wow that's all
it took to have Twitter
have you ever heard of uh like a coup
like a coup d'etat like with governments
uh you know I was I I read a lot of yeah
they're pretty cool yeah I read a lot of
history history jokes or history jokes I
read a lot of history books about uh
whatever and they talk about like a coup
and I'm like
so you literally just like walked into
the White House and you just said like
you know this is mine and like the
general has promised me that he's gonna
commit these soldiers to attack you know
what I mean it's like an interesting
concept you're like so it's all just
made up I guess like these rules that
we're we we live by this is just this is
fiction and that's kind of like what I
felt like he did he just walked he's
like well I I own this now thank you
have you seen uh you know Derek Lewis
the UFC fighter have you seen that
compilation of his thing where he says
just get up no so they're like Derek uh
you're big like knockout artist but like
you know the the knock on you've always
been like what if you get a wrestling
thing you know how's your Jiu Jitsu or
your training
it's just ain't real man and they're
like what he's like man you don't need
Jiu Jitsu just get up
and they're like he's like why I don't
want to stay on the ground with another
man between my legs no I'm not into that
like I'm not gonna do so I'm just gonna
get up they're like but you you need Jiu
Jitsu to get up he's like no I'm just
gonna get up and so so there's a clip of
him saying that and then there's like
it's like a six minute compilation of
literally somebody takes him down he
doesn't he just stands back up so
powerful that's how I feel that's what
Elon Musk did he's like nah just just
walk in yeah take it what do you mean
he's like well I'm just gonna walk in
with a sink
and take it so anyway he does this thing
where he just he says this is mine and
there's all these reporters outside of
Twitter's office and it's amazing for a
story they're waiting for the story
about something going wrong Elon comes
here oh there's a protest there's a walk
and so what happens is the first big
story that happens is there's a picture
of these two guys and uh kind of like
you know kind of like nerdy sort of
engineering looking guys and they're
holding giant cardboard boxes and it
says these two data scientists the data
Engineers data scientists were fired
today from Twitter here they're seen
walking out with their possessions and
their boxes and um and I saw it and
immediately something looked a little
off
because I was like this guy just looks
so goofy but I was like man that's
pretty believable you know there's a
bunch of goofy looking people are
working Tech but okay oh my God he looks
wild man they really found the perfect
character he looks pretty goofy and then
I read the name and it says but he but
he but he had a box in his hand so he
each had a brown box like which is just
foreign because like if you work at a
tech company like you you don't even
probably own anything you own enough
just to put in a book put your laptop in
your backpack and like if you do get
fired do they even like is that a thing
where you like hand people a box anymore
I don't know they played it perfectly so
then it says Rahul ligma and something
Johnson uh Daniel Johnson were fired
today blah blah and then and I saw that
and I was like oh my God this guy
executed a ligman like for those who
don't know
ligma is a is a little joke that people
play on the internet where it's like
like you say something about ligma and
then someone's like ligma what's like
I'm not familiar link my nuts all right
so that's the joke and they did this to
basically I think CNBC was the first one
who like reported it and then it just
kept getting the same photo kept getting
spread ever because everybody wanted
this story about and then
she was this CNBC reporter and I I the
original tweet said something like uh
we're at the scene of Twitter these two
Engineers just came out who said they're
the first to be laid off and it's just
so clear how defeated they are and like
there's like an audible or what does she
say she's like there's just a visible uh
they're just visibly defeated and
totally broken and Rahul ligma says now
he has no idea how he's gonna be able to
afford his Tesla payments uh and then
he's sitting there holding a Michelle
Obama book and so it's like him with his
box just holding this Michelle Obama
book I don't know why and he just said
it and she tweeted out like you know
this is just they say the first of many
that's going to happen it was just like
a crazy crazy scene so people are um
people are are have heard this part of
the story but now we got that my first
million exclusive juice on top of it so
somebody in our group chat knows this
guy who did this and he shared a text
message that the guy sent before he did
it so he goes
um he goes yo bro and the person says
sup he goes are you doing anything in
the next hour want to help me pull off a
stunt I'm at the gym and I need a box
LOL I'm gonna walk out in front of the
Twitter office with a box in my hand
there's hella TV Crews outside
and then this is literally how he pulled
this up and he just goes he gets an
empty box and a Michelle Obama book
there's nothing else in the box and we
watch out in the TV Crews go for it and
so so that was I thought amazing and
then he so that was like I mean what
kind of Genius is this person then he
goes
uh there's hella TV Crews let's go get
him there he goes he
bro the media is so dumb I literally put
five minutes of planning into this even
my uncle in India has seen the picture
now he goes he goes the first thing is
did you just see the cameras and just
walk out there he goes yeah basically I
got to the gym it's near Twitter's
headquarters I saw all these cameras and
so I just went and did it amazing that
is so funny the better who is this guy
he's like a founder of like a tech
startup basically he just did this
before Oh my God yeah I am ready to
invest and his thing says like stealth
startups I'm like I'm ready to invest in
whatever he's doing anything on TV
there's hella TV cameras name your price
ligma
so so he goes okay so that was him did
you see the interview with the other guy
Daniel Johnson no he also had a little
gem so his was on videos that they're
like you know um how do you feel about
this today he's like I don't know I just
gotta like I gotta go home I gotta talk
to my husband and wife and regroup
I don't know I just I just really want
to go home I really want to go home talk
to my husband and wife
the most San Francisco thing ever yeah
did anyone comment on that the news
didn't even like like they just played
the clip and then I saw that I was like
wow that is the funniest thing I've ever
heard perfect timing and these guys are
like you know comedic Geniuses basically
so yeah this is pretty gold amazingly
well played
um yeah do you want to talk about the
Elon war room like what he's actually
doing in there like do you want to talk
about that or not really have your phone
not really I mean like I I read that he
said like hey guys you have a week to
get this one thing done and I think that
that's cool that's that's a good way to
run things I'm nervous he's gonna screw
it all up and like because I make money
from Twitter so like I don't want it to
go away uh but uh of course chill bro
yeah yeah
I got Consulting calls to take uh so um
I don't really care though like when he
talks about this [__] I'm like this
doesn't impact me that much I don't I
don't care what you're gonna do well I
just want I don't care it's not gonna
impact me but I do find it interesting
how he's doing about this so basically
the report is he goes in and the first
report I thought again was another troll
but I guess this is real do you see this
he's like he told every engineer to
print out all the code that they've
committed and they've written in the
last three or six months and have it
ready for review did you see this why
print so you can just see the the pages
and then they change their mind like I
guess they realize how bad of an idea
that was and like you know an hour later
they're like Shred the papers actually
we're gonna review on the computer just
be prepared to review and so people are
like all these Engineers like I printed
out like you know 300 pages of code so I
guess I'll just thread this I don't know
what's going on here dude and what's
crazy is like if you go to
businessinsider.com the headline is like
you know I think it says like the toil
of working at Twitter and it's like
painting it like these people here's
their initial yeah this is like this is
what it's like to toil Elon musk's
Twitter the expectation is literally to
work 24 7. and is it really I think that
that's I swear to God straight clown
Behavior I cannot believe they're doing
that
I can believe it
and it says this is it one of the people
familiar said describing the feeling of
the company under musk your job is on
the line it's like dude your job's
always on the line uh like is it you
know like this isn't like it's not your
right to work at Twitter you dumbass uh
but I I uh I I thought it was funny
because like come on man like you're
you're coding this yeah you're gonna
have to work 50 hours maybe for a little
while but also I think a lot of
employees at Twitter are probably like
this is awesome we've been sitting on
our ass let's let's do it and that side
doesn't seem to be getting covered a lot
yeah and so he created I guess a war
room so he basically brought in a bunch
of people he trust so he brought in
people from his other companies like he
brought in his chief legal person that
guy's now like the general counsel
basically he brought in he created a war
room and now here's who's reported to be
in the war room it's uh
Elon his uh his his chief counsel then
it's Jason calacanus oh and then I think
Jason's Jason's amazing but like what
the hell does he know yeah I guess uh
sriram from a16z so just venture
capitalist who's a former PM who used to
work at Twitter is also you know how to
run at Twitter
um and Clubhouse and uh
Snapchat yeah and then also
um I guess like some other people some
Engineers or people from uh like boring
company or neural link or whatever like
some people he trust like his cousin is
there like and they basically just set
up shop and they were like all right
what we're gonna do with this thing and
they're like change the logged out page
it forces you to sign up now you should
be able to read tweets before you sign
in you know you sign up and then which
is like an experiment's been tried many
times before and there's like um you
know we need to have this verification
program you have five days to deliver
this I guess and so there's like sort of
uh trying to figure this out of you know
who stays who goes what are we building
how are we going to turn this thing
around and um
fascinating I wish I could be a fly on
the wall in this uh in this war room I
think that would be like probably the
most interesting thing to do right now
I think it would be awesome
um I hope they don't screw it up though
because I got some [__] courses I
gotta sell so don't screw it up
my point of view has always been very
simple which is all the things he
complains about are things that like
power users would be annoyed at on
Twitter like the Bots problem or
um you know verification or the
algorithm you know like not serving me
the tweets I want like the problem is
that just only I don't know whatever
like 300 million people use Twitter and
it's like you know five times smaller
than like the other big social services
and it doesn't really grow that much and
like
it's not like you know my mom doesn't
use Twitter because she's like oh
there's too many Bots if I tweet about
crypto that will tell me to buy crypto
that's not her problem she just doesn't
see value in it and like you know he
just says I don't get it yeah I don't
get it I I don't know why I would need
this like you know I don't I don't need
to check this whereas Instagram and
WhatsApp and like Snapchat have all
given her a reason that she needs to
have it like she needs to have Snapchat
if she wants to see more pictures of her
kids she needs to have Instagram if she
wants to keep up with what's going on
with like Bollywood or whatever right
like you know everybody finds a need in
the service and like that's the core
problem with Twitter is that the core
needed addresses is only for like people
like us and like it doesn't address the
need for a whole bunch of other people
on the planet and if they wanted it to
be more valuable then they would need to
do that
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new PRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better Happy
Halloween dude yeah you too I uh since
I'm not 12 I don't dress up I I don't
understand like shots fired at producer
Ben
well I just like don't understand why
people like obsessed over Halloween to
me it just seems like when your wife was
buying a wedding dress were you like
this is [__] you're gonna spend all
this money for something that you're
literally gonna use for three hours in
your entire life and that's how I feel
like Halloween is
you know what I mean I just find it like
to be the most impractical thing there
is it just it's a lot of work for like a
few hours bro you probably bought like a
a giant sled so you could do sled pushes
in your backyard like you know come on
I'm sure you have some ridiculous
purchase up your sleeve too
I have a sled
[Laughter]
uh producer Ben what are you you look
more like a figure skater or some like
like a figure skater in between rounds
like I don't I don't always want to put
the hood on but it's a narwhal it's got
like a little horn on top little horns
and my wife has a matching costume a
narwhal is just uh whale that has a yeah
if you're if you're a parent then I get
it but like for the people who work
really hard at uh this stuff to me I'm
just like that just seems like such a
wasted time my wife loves it she's this
person yeah my wife too she uh like we
bought a bunch of costumes whatever I'm
Aladdin which is pretty uh you know
stereotypical I felt uh you know lean in
bro is it racism if it's your wife yeah
lean in I say lean into it I got the
Cheryl Sandford Sanford book I'm gonna
lean in put some [__] man lean into
stereotypes
um but speaking of Halloween I did a
bunch of research about Halloween I
wanted to rant about it to you
um I'm sure you know a bunch of things
about Halloween because I feel like this
is like
like I'm not gonna say that because this
is a rabbit hole that's kind of obvious
and I feel like you know I went into
this rabbit hole and I saw some
footprints on the way out I was like I
think that's Sam's size 11 right there I
don't know what's going on but let me
tell you some things I found okay so uh
first and foremost Halloween okay what
what the heck is this so this was a uh
it's kind of crazy that today Halloween
is this like family neighborhood thing
where everybody you know young kids are
going out and getting candy uh older
kids are dressing up you know with an
excuse to dress up like kind of [__]
and like you know this is like you know
this is this giant giant occasion where
people are spending 10 billion dollars a
year now on Halloween is what gets spent
which is kind of crazy that's more than
almost any other holiday except for
Christmas which is off the charts at
almost a trillion dollars gets spent on
Christmas and so um so I was like what
the heck is this holiday who made this
up where'd this come from it's first of
all it's like some weird part of like
you know the Celtic calendar the Celtic
calendar I don't even know what it is
but like
[Laughter]
so so there was like all right there's
like this uh you know Festival where
they would like they're like oh the
demons are coming and so they would like
dress up as demons themselves and like
go dancing and whatever and that was
like to ward off the demons like Hey
we're already here and like that was the
logic which is pretty pretty weak logic
if you ask me and so uh you know then
something had the Pope says something
he's like oh this is you know November
1st is like the the day of the Saints or
whatever baby we in Catholic school we
just celebrated every year and so then
the 31st became All Hallows Eve and so
okay how did it go from that to kids
dressing up as Aladdin and going
trick-or-treating what was what was the
Gap it basically it was like for a while
it was this kind of like Lo like um
nobody really spent money on this it was
sort of like this more like adult dark
holiday where you would buy like certain
things you'd have people for dinner
maybe things like that and then over
time it got commercialized and what I
was trying to figure out where did it
get commercialized how did we go from
this like obscure pagan holiday to this
mainstream 10 billion dollars a year
thing and the best explanation I could
find was that there was like kind of a
society thing which was like people
wanted a holiday it was a good excuse to
celebrate they liked that it was commun
they could make a community and family
oriented over time rather than uh like
this kind of adult
um thing and then the last thing was
that retailers so like the biggest
winner from all of Halloween is Walmart
Walmart makes a killing on Halloween it
sells candy it sells costumes it sells
decorations and it sells it to like
everybody Across America and so what
happened was retailers would have this
giant spike in like kind of spring maybe
a little bit of Summer and then there
was this dead time until the holiday the
winter holidays and so they were like
okay sales always dip
let's figure out what we can do to make
sales not dip during that time so they
kind of needed to like invent an
occasion for you to spend on and so this
started which is pretty common right
like if you think about like you know
like bit there's like the the Hallmark
Lobby man they've like really been
pushing Valentine's Day on us for years
I mean I think that's like a that's like
a pretty common tactic I imagine Amazon
is thinking like Prime day is going to
be a holiday of like just random deals
and it's not like a coordinated attack
but it is like a bunch of people who all
have an incentive so they had an
incentive to do
um just to sell more stuff and put
something in the store that's gonna
drive people to come by and so I just
want to break down a couple of the
numbers in a couple other businesses so
like I said about 10 billion in spending
uh 3 billion of that is costumes 700
million of that is pet costumes which is
kind of crazy
um there's basically like you know three
million on 3 billion on candy
and there's like a huge amount like I
don't know like basically almost half
the country is going to like give out
candy during during Halloween which is
kind of an insane level of adoption
that's going on so Walmart's the biggest
winner they they not only make a bunch
of money they spend a bunch of money
advertising during this period they'll
spend like
tens of millions of dollars in the week
of Halloween just like blasting ads and
so do all the companies that are stocked
inside their Skittles Cheetos lunchable
everybody's got like a Halloween themed
thing and so a couple of the interesting
finds I had when I was doing this so the
first is a lot of people know about
Spirit the spirit store right and people
have heard about this but like the
backstory of spirits were kind of cool
have you ever heard the backstory of how
it got started it's owned by a popular
company what's who's it owned by oh your
favorite dude it's your your Thursday
night date night Spencers Spencers
that's what I thought yeah like Spencer
is like uh you know like a Hot Topic
alternative Spencer's also owns Spirit
Halloween yeah so they so the way this
started was it's like in California in
the 80s this guy owned a woman's
clothing store and he was in October
again traditionally a super slow sales
month and so he's just sitting there not
really getting much sales he looks
around everybody's struggling except for
one store he sees that this one
Halloween
um store has a line out the door and so
he's like well I'm not selling [__]
anyways and so he just turned like
three-fourths of a store into a
Halloween store just for the month of
October and so it's his women's Boutique
so there's like women's clothes in like
a quarter of the store and then
three-fourths became Halloween stuff and
it it really works and so he just does
that again the next year he's like oh
that's my Halloween Playbook but now
he's like all right just forget my store
I'll just open up another store and
another store just for the month and so
um that's their model these guys
basically what they do is they go find
vacant property so
you know an empty box and they say hey
landlord you don't have a lease well
I'll lease it for two months how about
that and the landlords initially were
like well no like what about a two-month
lease like no thank you they're like
okay well look here's my offer if you
don't have a tenant by July might as
well take it some revenue is better than
no revenue and like especially after the
2008 real estate crash this became like
a pretty enticing option for landlords
to try to recoup some money and so they
do these two month leases and uh it's a
pop-up Halloween store same place every
time no different places they even have
a kickout clause so they say hey look
you could take how could I get more real
estate look if you find if you do find a
good tenant who you want to do a
long-term lease you can just kick us out
like like any time you could just kick
us out basically and so they found this
like no-brainer proposition to landlords
and so they do these pop-ups they now
have 1400 stores so like Fast rewind
back to
um you know like 2010 they only had you
know 700 stores and the whole Halloween
spend is on the same Trend so like I
said 10 billion this year Well rewind to
2010 that's when I graduated from
college it was 5 billion rewind to 2005
it was only like 3 billion and so that's
like kind of a big like just during our
you know lifetime our adult lifetime
this thing is like you know more than
doubled in in size and so um I don't
imagine that by the way all that work
for a week like I I know a guy who owns
a Christmas tree light show business
that I can't reveal how big it is but
whatever number you're thinking of how
much Remnant does triple times it bite
times no times it by 20. we're talking
like nine figures and Christmas tree
light show means what you pay twenty
dollars and you and your family drive
through a park and you look at light
shows and basically he's going to staff
of I don't even know how many steps he
is I think over a hundred they work all
year round for four weeks of work can
you imagine what your company's like
like what happens if there's like a
terrorist attack or uh you know like
whatever or or a covid I mean something
happens we're just like all 50 weeks
worth of work is ruined for those two
weeks do you know what I mean yeah that
is the risk that is the risk with these
like right now like it's Halloween right
today there the whole company is working
on next year's Halloween real estate how
they're going to do the logistics to
like because they just get an empty
shell they gotta pop up the whole store
get all the inventory there do all the
decorations there and then run the staff
the store just for this like you know
real Blitz and 90 of the traffic comes
in the two weeks before Halloween
because their main proposition is just
like for people who were you know who
procrastinated it's like hey it's too
late even now to order online so you
know just come into the store and just
get what you can get and uh it's that
big of a business they do like a billion
dollars a year in Revenue um the spirit
store so that's just kind of crazy for
billion dollars and basically like
probably a three week time period for
for the majority of that
um of that spend eight percent of all
candy sales of the Year happen like on
Halloween it's really crazy that's wild
and so what a wild stat here's some
other interesting little businesses that
were around this okay so have you ever
heard of rubies
no what is rubies rubies is probably the
biggest I think costume maker I don't
know if they're still the biggest that
they were at a point in time so here's
the kind of interesting story for rubies
uh started in New York and they're like
oh we're doing decorations and costumes
for Halloween Halloween wasn't as big of
a deal
it's like in the 70s they were doing
this and um at the time Halloween
costumes were all the same it was all
just ghosts and witches but then in the
70s and 80s it transitioned into
basically like Hollywood and it was like
oh movie characters and like TV
characters what became like the big
thing
and so and Ruby's kind of fell behind
because there were these other companies
uh Collegeville and Ben Cooper that like
got all the licenses so they were
winning they were crushing it and poor
rubies was just sort of like puttering
along
until
that fateful thing happened I didn't
even know about this but there was
something called the cyanide killer you
ever hear about this there was this big
Scandal where
I guess in Tylenol packages yeah we got
laced with Cyanide and people and they
never caught they never caught the
person never caught the guy and it
scared a bunch of people like holy [__]
Tylenol like this like safe thing how
many people died like three or four I'm
not sure I think it was more than that
uh but it was a big story that
definitely was big news and so people so
candy sales plummet
um you know like people start getting
pretty afraid and so these companies got
a little over their skis because
everything was going so great and they
start to falter during this uh sort of
like this crash when people started to
the Halloween sales crash because people
did not want to go eat candy from
strangers during the sort of like
cyanide uh you know rush I guess and so
rubies ends up buying up Ben Cooper and
Collegeville and basically consolidates
all the licenses Under One Roof during
that time and so now they have Disney
Marvel whoever they are like and they
their job is basically there's like a
you would think this is like I don't
know a bunch of theater Geeks that run
this company but in actuality like their
big thing they have to do right is uh is
like you know operations for the supply
chain like cash management no no
forecasting they gotta predict who is
going to be popular next year for
Halloween so they're like okay Donald
Trump is a trump mask is going to be
here or here or here and um and then
they work with all the studios the
studios give them like a little like
sketch sheet of like hey here's the
movies coming out next year and the year
after and here's who's the good guy
here's the bad guy and here's what the
costumes look like and like you know
you're under extreme lock and key but
like you know we make a lot of money we
make the movie industry makes hundreds
of millions off of Halloween costume
royalties they get like an eight to ten
percent royalty and so they're like all
right fine you can get access to these
designs in order to start prepping for
dude I Wonder Costumes I wonder what
their research methodology is you know
we've talked about that company wgsn it
always interests me it's a 100 million
dollar a year business that does like 30
million in profit yeah and all they do
is they help I mean they all they do is
simple but it is like a pretty amazing
thing but they like help they help
predict which color is going to be
popular so Starbucks make sure that
other
labels on [__] is like the right colored
pink or like apparently they predicted
that pineapples were going to be popular
did you know that pineapple was a
popular thing this year yeah yeah I'm
all about it and they like somehow knew
that and they're saying next year it's
going to be the lemon which I don't I
don't know is that really what they said
are you just making that one up I think
it yes I think it was the lemon uh like
next year lemons are gonna be like a new
thing instead of pineapple which I don't
even know how you would draw a lemon on
like an iPhone case I mean it just looks
like in the Sun but anyway they said
that like
such a wonderful problem your brain just
went to well like have yours you know
like pineapples on iPhone cases it's
like how do you make like a round like
yellow thing there's like no density to
it like I don't know we can Workshop
that afterwards so uh so so so I think
you know these guys probably you know
you know like that Meme like the hello
hello fellow kids or whatever little
children like the guy shows up at the
high school he's like 40 years old he
got a skateboard on his back and he's
like yeah okay it's like what is the
good you know what's the good Buzz this
year and like you know they're trying to
figure out like what's gonna be hot
um yeah I don't know I don't know the
research method but I am I am intrigued
but basically they got to be fortune
tellers they got to figure out through
movies politics
all that stuff is it Pokemon is it
Wonder Woman is it Trump is it what what
is it gonna be the costumes and so so
that's one interesting one
um a couple other you know pretty
interesting
um pretty interesting things I'll give
you some like I'll give you some like
smaller Niche like side hustle things so
um so first uh haunted houses so haunted
houses apparently do 300 million dollars
a year which kind of it's crazy it's
kind of a big number for something
that's like useful you know like dude I
hate haunted houses six days a year
what do you go uh I've been I'm not like
I'm not a big like thrill seeker like
roller coaster haunted house kind of guy
I'm not like afraid
I don't pay money to be scared that's my
that's my rule of movies and haunted
houses I I pay money to do the opposite
yeah it's like you know those guys who
pay girls to like you know slap them and
stuff it's like no thanks you know uh
pretty sure I'm pretty sure I should be
getting paid if I'm getting scared or
slapped that's my rule and I'm sticking
to it
um so so there's like you know haunted
house is kind of interesting there's a
guy who um somebody tweeted this at me
they're like yo this local one near our
place and I did the math um so this
place is like small like so what they're
doing is uh they basically take like a
vacant property same thing as the spirit
store they take a vacant property they
say hey we'll cut you a check for 10 15
grand if we can use your house right or
they'll they'll they'll rent a property
or they'll find a vacant property and
they basically just use it for the month
they have this operational thing where
they can just spin up the haunted house
and then they charge like 40 bucks you
know to enter and you can sort of do the
math and realize man they're probably
making half a million to a million
dollars in about a about a month just
off these things and they have like it's
pretty crazy how like you know as a
little side hustle you could do a
haunted house let me give you some other
ones that I think are kind of
interesting
there's a guy who created this website
called zombie pumpkins you ever seen
this no so I think it's
zombiepumpkins.com so two million people
a year go to this site just to print out
a stencil that they can use to carve
their pumpkin so he was like you know
what uh if you go try to do pumpkin
carving it's gonna be a pretty generic
face I'm gonna make like super
accurately drawn things so you could
have like a really dope looking pumpkin
like you can have like this is a really
cool site really like you know Michael
Jackson looking pumpkin it'll look like
it if you just follow my stencil and so
uh you know two million people go to
this thing it gets like a million of
those hits you know like in the last
week of October or something and uh you
know he donates a bunch of the money
that that comes from this to uh to
charity which I thought was pretty cool
and he charges money so you pay money
and you get stencils yep and every year
he releases new ones uh okay here's
another one pumpkin Steins so how would
you like a pumpkin that instead of
carving a pumpkin it looks like
something what if the pumpkin just grew
and only looked like like a Frankenstein
hit that's what this guy did so this
guy's got a crazy story he's like a I
don't know he's like some farmer
somewhere and he spent four years trying
to solve this problem he's like what if
I could just grow a pumpkin that was
already a decoration
so you don't have to do any work so he
tried like this uh pumpkin Stein like
Frankenstein yeah he tries to grow it
doesn't work doesn't work doesn't work
finally the fourth year he's like what
if I tried this like I don't know type
of seed or whatever it was and he got it
to grow into this mold and the mold
basically just looks like a Frankenstein
head and so he started selling them and
he does like you know a few hundred
sales and he does a few thousand sales
retailers start coming to him he opts to
go with Sam's Club because he's like you
know what like he was selling these for
a hundred dollars a pumpkin he's like
you know what Sam's Club we could sell
for 30 and make money doing that with at
their volume and these are amazing these
are amazing and so he goes and he's like
all right uh he's like this can be kind
of a thing
he said he got 90 000 orders last year
so like that's like four or five million
dollars in sales of these uh pumpkins he
started going to other farms and bribing
them being like hey I'll pay you 11
ahead follow this blueprint I need more
production I cannot possibly keep up
with the production at my rate and so he
goes and he gives other Farms like
eleven dollars per pumpkin that they can
produce that can be sold this way and
then they had they had like a
malfunction and like the face still
looked right but the back got all
screwed up and it like looks like it
like exploded and then that was way more
popular people are like oh that's cool
it like exploded in the back and he's
like oh [__] now I gotta figure out how
to do this intentionally it's like this
crazy little like you know like
accidental you know side Hobby
wow these are cool
um another one Home Depot have you heard
about the 12-foot skeleton
no so this is like one of these like
viral I think maybe from Tick Tock I
don't know where but like my wife has
been talking about this she's like oh I
really want to get the 12 foot thing
it's always sold out and I was like it
can't be that I mean like let's just go
to Home Depot and get it like have you
seen Home Depot it's just like full of
[__] like this is the way they're just
like out on every Home Depot she's like
you don't understand and she shows me
there's like Buy and Sell Groups on
Facebook where people are buying these
things for a thousand dollars plus like
they retailed for like 300 or something
like that and ebays they're selling for
a thousand dollars and it became such a
hit Home Depot figured out this giant
lawn uh skeleton uh was like the big hit
then lows came out this year and Lowe's
was like the 12-foot mummy and I was
like wow you know who's gonna come up
with the 12 foot one inch you know um
you know ghost next year it's like this
crazy little Trend but there's all these
things so all these things that really
weren't categories before are becoming
categories like the inflatable lawn you
know decorations are just like surging
in popularity different types of candy
different types of costumes like it's
all sort of surging in popularity
because people are just more and more
willing to spend I got thinking I was
like why is Halloween so awesome I love
Halloween
um you know you don't have the spirit
you're sort of the um the Grinch of
Halloween as as you're known
um and I realized
Halloween is the anti-holiday it's not
the cookie cutter warm and fuzzy it's
dark it's kind of more adult it's more
creative it's one of the few creative
holidays and um social media is the Boom
for Halloween because social media what
is social media it's a hey look at me
and Halloween is the perfect hey look at
me moment it's hey look at my house hey
look at my costume hey look at my body
hey look at my candy hey look at my kids
I look at everything right so it's the
hey look at me thing and also it's an
excuse to act like a kid and I'm bullish
on anything that gives people an excuse
to act like a kid uh I think that's why
Burning Man is popular I think that's
why Halloween is popular and um you know
even things like the ice cream Museum
and stuff like that I think is is you
know really popular for that reason
dude it feels like you just prepared a
debate on why Halloween's great and why
I should dig it and you have totally won
me over
so you're saying there's a chance yeah
like you just put together this big
speech on why Halloween is cool and I'm
into it I think it's awesome this
12-foot Skeleton thing is awesome this
pumpkin Stein uh is awesome I'm all
about it this is awesome so let me tell
you more ideas or um or a little little
niche so I'll tell you a couple niches
and a couple ideas Niche thing we had a
guy come rig up lights to our house this
week because he did every single house
in our neighborhood and we just moved
into this place and then our neighbor
was like oh yeah you want lights you got
to hit the lights guy he's booked but
like if he can try to squeeze you and
you'll have lights for this season
everybody dude you're just getting
sucked in all the Suburban traps by the
way for the listener I went to Sean's
house uh the other day for dinner and I
walked in and I'm like oh that's a
really cool uh kids shopping cart like
he's got like a play like checkout aisle
and I was like oh wow that cart says
Target on it and he goes yeah uh or
maybe it was your wife but if one of you
guys were like yeah this has been one of
the most in-demand toys we had to like
find this cart on eBay for however we
flipped one and we bought the other yeah
you're like we had to get this car like
the kids wanted this car which they
didn't but you guys did I think probably
the moms won this card yeah the moms it
was like we wanted this Target toy cart
and I just thought
you know that's kind of interesting now
I'm hearing this you are totally
becoming a Suburban Dad this is awesome
I'm I like this side of you sir you know
I have a fanny pack
you know it was equipped for this life
so this guy comes up comes over and he's
like I'm like how much for the lights
and he's like I'll do it and I'll do it
this day this morning you get like a one
hour window and
um it's like 600 to put up lights uh you
know like 200 bucks for the lights
themselves they last you for 10 years
and then um it'll be like 60 bucks to
take them down in January and I was like
all right I guess like I'm not gonna
[__] climb up there so yeah go ahead
like you know either We're not gonna
have lights or like we're gonna get in
the spirit of things and this guy just
cleaned up around the neighborhood it
took him an hour but why would he do it
this way he should do it where I'll come
and pick them up on uh like right after
Thanksgiving and hey by the way while
I'm here do you want Christmas lights
well these were Christmas lights
actually it's like they start the
Christmas stuff now and then I hear you
okay I thought it's Halloween lights
whichever whatever that is yeah I don't
even know but he should start being like
you want Halloween and I'll do a bulb
change in like November he should be
upselling he was too honest of a guy in
general because like he was like 60
bucks to take him down I was like bro
once you put the lights up you could
charge me six thousand dollars to take
them down what am I gonna do like you
know like where's the gouging you
shouldn't have even told me that price
until like gen one you should have
called me like hey dude you need those
down uh it's actually illegal to have
those up here right now
you look like a redneck you gotta take
those things down we were pretty redneck
when I was young and we'd leave them up
all year round and we'd call them party
lights
yeah well they're called February lights
now they're March lights
[Music]
um so this guy I'm pretty sure this guy
made like twenty thousand dollars this
month in my one neighborhood with like
essentially zero cost
um all he had to do was know how to
string up lights and um you know that's
a skill that I think can be learned and
so like you know there is a like
neighborhood side hustle here that I
think is like a 10 to 20 000 side also
like there's you know probably like 100
houses in this area flyer them and then
um go start putting up lights and just
say hey knock on the door yeah we just
put up their lights would you guys want
lights this year like I think that's a
that's kind of an easy win
um okay let me give you now some ideas
so you don't like haunted houses
uh I'm fine with a haunted house but man
the effort to get out there is probably
gonna be cold gotta get the kids ready
gotta go in the car you know all that
stuff
why isn't there a haunted house I could
just do from the seat of my chair at
home that's right VR haunted house if
you ever put on a VR headset
there's one thing VR is kind of amazing
at VR is kind of amazing at this like
immersive experience where you can like
look at you look right and you could
just get scared like if you've ever done
the demo where you're rock climbing and
they're like look down or you look down
it's legit scary and then they'll make
your character like start to slip yeah
you get that feeling in your stomach and
so VR haunted house no brainer I don't
know if there is one or not but like
you know these there are I think a
hundred VR apps that do over a million
dollars a year I feel like the VR
Halloween app the VR Haunted House app
you know you could sell this thing for
20 bucks a pop and probably make you
know I don't know a couple hundred
thousand if not a million dollars in in
a year just with the amount of sales
that go on in VR
um it's nobody and they'll feature you
right because you're cool content for
that month so you'll get like free
promotion basically through the Oculus
store
that's an eight I dig it all right cool
um okay my next one is gonna be
spirit store for Christmas am I dumb is
there no spirit store for Christmas
I don't know but I do know that my wife
is like your wife where like this
weekend we are walking around and she's
like anything that had a pumpkin
flavored candle she was walking in and
like she bought like a caramel apple
she's like I gotta get a caramel apple
today like we have to have one today
yeah what is that [__] Pavlov
been doing to our wives man like there
is something with this certain scent in
certain color that like you know I must
have I must have it's like uh in my life
I just learned this weekend have you
ever heard of nesting do you know what
that is yes I didn't know what that was
so I just thought it was like dude by
the way it's it's so like for the single
guys listening uh I guess for 98 of our
audience
yeah to all the neck beards out there
for all the people listening to this on
a Peloton
in your one bedroom San Francisco
apartment but basically when a woman I
guess is like I don't know when it
happens but like I think later in the
pregnancy by the pregnancy she starts to
Nest I guess that means like you start
like preparing for the baby you want to
like clean constantly basically you want
to have an environment where the baby
can come to and be safe until you want
to clean you want to organize you want
to make sure that there's no corners
that's so that's a real thing well I I
definitely experienced it like we were
like what's going on that other people
who had already acted like oh nesting
yeah baby's coming soon you know you
could sort of feel this it's like is
your wife suddenly cleaning organizing
all of a sudden the to-do list just gets
like knocked out because it's like oh
there's like burst of clarity and energy
and like
urgency around preparing the home for a
certain thing
that's crazy so you know it's
interesting like we we we think that we
are like these civilized like creatures
different from an animal but then like
there's these these situations that
happen for example if you're a man of
someone like disrespects you publicly
you start feeling this like what is this
rage I feel inside of me like I want to
go do I want to go fight right now or
like or like with a woman it's like the
nesting thing like there's all these
like things and having a kid is like a
really good example of when like these
weird things just start happening that
like I I thought I was different I
thought I wasn't just one of those
animals but it turns out I'm just a
beast like you know the rest of the the
animal kingdom and nesting is one of
them and maybe
there's something about Halloween where
just Sarah just has to drink or eat
pumpkin flavored [__] just constantly
well and it's just and like it's the
same way with Christmas she's like oh we
gotta go get the cinnamon thing yep I'm
like we don't need it but she's like no
no it's a hot thing that I'm gonna hold
with both of my hands near my nose like
a small koala and it's like what is this
what is this position of that all women
assume during during the winter so the
spirit CEO even said this he goes fall
the Turning of the leaves the pumpkin
spice latte and the spirit store we have
become a symbol of the changing of
Seasons people now wait for our store to
pop up that's how they Mark time the
passage of time in their lives so
anyways I thought
you know I thought why is it there a
spirit for Christmas what what does
Spirit do well
decorations
desserts
and bag gone good gift ideas that's the
three d's of spirit
you are superb and I'm gonna start
calling you dead
[Laughter]
guy I needed another dude the dag gone
good gift ideas so Christmas triple D
baby yeah triple D has decorations it
has specific dessert eggnog candy canes
all this stuff and you need gift ideas
you need to go try out toys and things
like that and so you know Hallmark tries
to capture this I think they're doing it
wrong I think Spirit needs to get in the
spirit of things Spirit needs to pop up
for Halloween
stick around for Thanksgiving and that
Christmas push and then wind things down
right after Valentine's Day that's the
spirit you need to get you need to get
on this this six to eight month program
I'm sure you've thought of this and you
have a good reason why you don't but I I
like to play pretensely you know like I
think that's something that you and I or
whoever listening don't think about
enough is when you're thinking about a
company to build you really do you think
this would be awesome to run and being
CEO of the holiday company
would be awesome yeah I mean that would
just be like a fun thing are you
changing the world nah are you having a
blast for sure you're in the season as
we say at the Holiday company
yeah that's this is it's the holidays
what a beautiful word yeah which is
completely underused yeah I love the
tears uh yeah so I'm about this we're on
to something so um okay a couple other
uh interesting things so this pet
costume thing I think is like a real
Trend
um you know we've seen pet vitamin
companies like zestypaw sell for 600
million dollars we've seen pet ever you
know pets is like a huge Niche and so if
700 million is spent a year on pet
costumes I feel like you could just kind
of like
I mean I I can't tell you off top of my
head who is the the go-to for Pep you
know for for pet costumes and so that
tells me you know there's more than
enough room on the e-commerce side for
it
um
you know the story behind
halloweenclassrooms.com is also crazy
it's all the same thing it's basically
like somebody stumbled into this idea
and then couldn't even keep up a demand
as Halloween grew and now it's effing
huge all right so that's my that's my
Halloween rant that's mine that was a
good one uh you know breakdown and
backstory
um let's see did I miss anything dude so
I want to talk about a few things well
we go to this one topic really quick
it's I think it's only okay so I don't
want to spend that much time on it but
then I want to hear your silly story the
Twitter thing and the Warren Buffett
thing I think these are all those are
all awesome but this is just one thing
to put on your radar have you heard of
this company called humane
Humane is this the um like phone on your
chest yes so basically this is just it's
it's better for the shitty pitch you
made
I I don't actually know what it is and I
don't think anyone knows what it is but
basically I saw this YouTube video
talking about it's the first time I've
ever heard about it which is interesting
because they've raised 130 million
dollars from like some of the best VCS
out there and the people who start it is
it's this husband and wife company I
think they spent like one of the the
husband spent 20 years at iPhone or at
Apple building the iPhone I think he was
like one of like a six or ten person
team to like the original team to come
up with the iPhone his wife was also a
director of engineering I think of of
apple or something like pretty
impressive like that and they've
recruited like a hundred plus employees
most all are from Apple like 60 or 70 of
them are from Apple and they're like
apple Ballers they're not just like the
average just like entry-level person and
so it's kind of an interesting signal
and they filed for all these patents one
is like a wearable multimedia device and
cloud computing platform with laser
projecting projections another one's
like a portable yeah I mean that could
that could go anyway you know what I
mean like we're gonna
another one's like a portable battery
pack I mean like they've done all these
amazing things they don't even have a
website like you can't you can't really
learn anything about it you go to the
website first of all if you go to the
website you got to commit three typos to
get there it's Q dot ma
like any Humane but split up with three
two different periods and then you get
there and it's a picture of like the sun
and it just says
like I forgot where it said like change
everything yeah so I have a I have a
strong take on that but let me finish
this which is basically their whole
point is that they view phones as a
divider between us and the world and
they want your phone or whatever it is
going to replace a phone to be an
extension of our bodies which that's
like pretty vague I don't know what the
hell that means but I guess it means
like they want to build a new iPhone but
it's not going to be a handheld device
it's going to be like clothes that you
wear or lenses in your eyes I'm not
exactly sure but
two tanks one I completely agree and I
think that as an industry we're like way
and we're we're too early to say that
there's something actionable right now
but I do think in like 10 20 years
we're going to be anti-phone we're going
to be like like what the [__] you're
looking at this [__] this is like cancer
why are you doing this why are you what
you're smoking what are you doing
smoking it's kind of like we look at
smoking number two I think unfortunately
I don't know you guys Bethany and Imran
I think those are the two Founders I'm
sure you're wonderful people but
I think any company that raises that
much money and has a site that says
change everything and has raised 120
million dollars and has never shown
anything
I think they always fail nine out of ten
times I think that they're gonna fail
because of their hubris and it's like
what the hell are we making what's one
that didn't fail is there an example
like quibby was the most recent one that
was like this and uh quibby failed magic
leap before that magically failing in
progress
um what were the other ones like Lucero
that one failed I mean the only one I
could think of is jet.com and uh but one
would argue that that didn't succeed
one would say it didn't fail but like
they probably sold slightly above the
valuation in which that they raised that
yeah like I don't know if the underlying
business was healthy or not it I I
didn't feel like jet.com became this
main yeah big consumer thing that was
going on but like you know who knows the
world is really big maybe there were a
ton of loyaljet.com users who were you
know using it all the time and the
business was working but it did seem
like it was the the team the story the
technology that got acquired by Walmart
in order to make Walmart's online thing
better but nonetheless still a definite
win
Mark Laurie friend of the Pod love the
guy uh you know owns a [__] NBA team
so like it worked you know in terms of
creation owns a place in my heart more
importantly but like you know how many
of these dream big raised big hype big
build instilled for multiple years and
then like launch with the world changing
device
um or world changing product
[Laughter]
if I had a nickel every time it happened
I mean I would maybe have a dime yeah
you know
it did happen a lot like you're opening
game Minesweeper it looks like that
um you know okay so so here's a couple
things
um number one we did talk about this
before because when they came out the
patent I think got leaked and it looked
like at that time the device was some
kind of clip-on sort of like camera that
you basically would wear on your your
chest
um sort of like a GoPro but for
everybody
I don't know if this is still the
product or not but I remember that was
the the idea
um and it was like oh that's cool you'd
kind of have this like hands-free you
know camera audio device that sort of
thing oh yes I do remember that and so
that was kind of interesting but that
that would only be to capture it
wouldn't be to
um he couldn't like look at that and
read something or watch video or
anything like that so it wouldn't
totally replace the phone but I'll say a
couple things I think they're solving
the right problem which is the phone is
not the last that's not the Last
Frontier there's certainly going to be
some kind of wearable device after this
is it a watch is it glasses is it uh
something like this is it a drone that's
floating above your head all the time I
don't know but like most likely it's
going to be glasses
um you know that seems to be where
everybody's going and so like we'll see
but definitely will happen and
definitely will change the world when
whoever does get that form factor right
so it is inevitable in my opinion the
next thing the phone really is causing
like you know a lot of damage and
problems in terms of how Society like
you know with the extreme strength that
came from this device that helps us
never get lost never be bored never
never be alone all that good stuff you
know I remember going to a doctor and he
was like he did a scan he's like oh yeah
you have a little you know slight thing
up here C4 C5 whatever like your your
vertebrae he's like uh I was like oh
[__] like what did I you know did I what
did I looking down he's like oh no
everybody has this now it's from looking
at the phone he's like it's like the
most chronic problem in the in the
country right now is people's vertebrae
are like you know messed up because
their neck is always craned down and I
was like oh damn man I gotta really
start raising my phone higher when I'm
looking
I gotta really get like a selfie stick
or something
and he sells them yeah
[Laughter]
okay so I think they're solving the
right problem I also think that the TR
like people think the the common thing
people would say and this is kind of the
White Knight thing that I hate which is
I don't want to have more technology I
don't I don't want to have you know
classes that have my phone on them and
my eyes all day like shoot me now I'm
like all right I will shoot you now
you're in your compression I'm gonna
kill you
your impression of uh of a white knight
you're basically like a white
Californian guy I think you put a little
more like
lowerness in your voice and I think
you've got the the best white guy
impression I've ever heard of yeah
social media
all I can say is they need a Raul in
their life so we'll talk about in a
second but um but dude so so I think
that there's this idea of like oh you
know social media is too crazy I want to
detox I want to uh I'm not going to uh I
don't want more technology oh my God I
don't want to live in a world like that
guess what it's coming and you're gonna
love it you're gonna do it and like yes
it will have some negatives associated
with it like anything but like it is
going to happen what one thing that's
gonna happen with it is this uh
Zuckerberg has this law he he said I
don't know if you remember this back he
coined this term Zuckerberg's law did
you ever hear what this was no he tried
to get away from he said it one time in
an interview never said it again because
it was like sounded bad but like it
stuck with me which was because every
year people are basically willing to
share up to twice as much as they were
willing to share the year before so in
terms of like you know we weren't
sharing our status updates about what we
were doing all the time but then like
you know what Twitter comes out and now
people are just you know sharing every
random thought on their mind we weren't
sharing our location before but then
Foursquare and others came out now we
started sharing location uh photos we
were only sharing you know we weren't
sharing online then we shared albums
then we shared a single photo and then
with Snapchat we'll just share like you
know tons of photos because they all
disappear so like basically as long as a
product can unlock there is like pent up
demand to share twice as much as you're
currently sharing and I feel this all
the time there are so many moments in
the day that I wish I had captured my
kids did something cute or somebody you
know my trainer said something awesome
to me in a workout and I'm not I don't
have my hands on the keyboard at that
moment to capture that video that note
or that that image and so I think that
there is a big pent-up demand to be able
to share way more moments or capture way
more moments and share some portion of
those than is happening today and that
will happen with either glasses uh you
know like maybe a drone camera or like a
this wearable thing on your chest so I
think those things are all working for
it the thing that's working against it
is once you get this cute ass domain and
you raise like 100 million dollars and
you go into stealth and you hire a
hundred people and you're basically like
we're gonna change the world
um you're basically saying I'm going to
you know like follow this path you know
I'm gonna walk off this Cliff like the
many before me that many companies
before me that have done this like hey
magically if I could see you down there
right like you know that is the the
challenge with some of this stuff
yeah I don't think it's gonna work but I
think it's a cool cool move I'm glad
they're doing it yeah it's like what do
you say face tattoos yeah it's like hey
like what do you say to his wife and
they're like hey
you want to feel what it's you want to
feel what it feels like to spend 130
billion dollars like you know what I
mean they're just like like you feel
like spending money like you know they
just like are coming over the way just
to blow this cash but um pick one more
of these things for the last few minutes
Suli or Warren Buffett they both are
incredibly interesting uh let's do this
what we want all right so he tells the
story he goes you know when I sold my
company tiny uh tiny Co was the name of
his his company was a mobile gaming
company he says there was two parts
there was our original games that we had
been making like Tiny Monsters Tiny Zoo
stuff like that and our license game
like we made the Family Guy game the
Harry Potter game Marvel game
and we got acquired uh in the choir the
guy the people who bought us they really
wanted the like the licensed famous IP
games and so after the acquisition we
decided to sell the first one and there
was a bunch of potential acquirers and
they you know one of them you know one
offered us 500k for it I thought it was
a good offer but we could get more
so I created a new bidder I hit up a
former engineer from time to go and I
told him to bid I said
you're gonna need to offer like a
million dollars like two times the
current offer to get the deal because
you're just like some random guy and he
did and it was a lot more than James
City imagine it was more than the market
price and as such he won the bit and I
was like congrats all right you had a
million dollars right it was only a
million million dollars I was like
congrats you got it okay now here's the
deal you we've underinvested in these
games you should you know just you got
to work like 60 hours a week just put
some money into ads to grow it add these
features that'll help you know retain it
better and like you're gonna be able to
three or four extra Revenue in the next
12 months
and the guy like you know sat there and
he's like
I got a better idea uh he's like I'm
working today at as an engineer at this
company uh I'm just gonna quit and then
he's like I look he's like I'm just
gonna do the absolute minimum to keep
this thing like refreshed and working
and so he goes instead of doing more
work he goes you know what I'm good with
this I'm just gonna tap out of the
workforce at age 31 and I'm gonna retire
I don't need to spend any more money I'm
gonna live you know uh like within my
means and like this app that I just
bought for a million dollars is going to
keep giving me cash flow for you know
forever I don't need a job anymore
um and I'll just always maintain it so
it keeps bringing me that cash flow and
in the meantime I'm gonna work on my
hobby projects and other software things
that just scratch my itch and he goes
and he goes then you know just like the
world started working in his favor on on
top of that he goes you know like epic
and apple gone into a lawsuit Apple had
to change their the Rev share deal so
they said for for anybody making less
than a million in Revenue will give you
30 uh instead of take a 30 cut we'll
take a 15 cut so immediately profit went
up by 15 for this guy he goes the
business has generated more than 3
million in profit since he bought it the
purchase price assumed that Revenue
would go down over time but it remained
steady and actually grew during covid
and he goes takeaways the only way to
win the rat race is to opt out this is a
takeaway that I understand
intellectually but I have not accepted
emotionally frankly I'm still blown away
by my friends Act of saying yeah I have
enough
and uh he goes number two when I tell
you something to buy something buy it
and I tell you to work harder on
something don't do it and
um and then he was like you know you
know the self-serving part of this
thread was like you know a lot of
businesses have these little baby
businesses inside that are undervalued
like if you have one of these like you
know I want to buy one I think these
businesses don't have a lot of value in
them and so um
uh and so uh
Yeah so basically and I think by the way
he didn't just buy the whole million
with a million dollars of cash up front
he uh finances yeah right so he put down
maybe three 400 000 and finance the rest
uh as an example and so would you ever
do that would you could you see yourself
tapping out
yeah I think about that all the time uh
you know really yeah not tapping out
forever but I feel like uh tapping out
in the sense that I really have this
urge to work on
whatever the most like creative and fun
project is which might make zero dollars
or negative dollars but don't you do
that now in a way like that's why how I
started this podcast my plan when I
started this podcast was I was like I
think I'll probably lose 10 grand a year
all in on production
um you know paying my editor you know a
couple hundred bucks a month and like
you know I was like you know booking the
studio you know four times a month
that's 400 bucks I was like I probably
net will lose 10 grand I'll have some
sponsors but net will lose 10 grand I
was like I'm totally happy to do that uh
because I think this Project's gonna be
a lot of fun and instead of starting a
new business
I started this podcast and this podcast
turned out to be like my favorite thing
I've ever done but the best project I've
ever started and actually turned out to
be a pretty good business actually on
top of that and um I kind of want to do
that again so I kind of want to go look
at like what's something I would be
willing to lose money doing because it's
that fun to me or that intriguing to me
because I think that that's probably a
better signal of like what I really want
to do and therefore we'll take an
interesting shot at doing something dude
I think that like a lot of people dream
about retiring
um and I've I've a few times in my
career I've taken like as much as a
month off to a year off sabbatical
yeah I used to call it a sambatical and
uh I was like I'm on a sandbatical and
uh every single time I love it at first
and at the end I'm like dude I gotta go
do something I can't I can't just do
this I like it like your friends can't
hang out with you on a Wednesday at you
know one o'clock like you're just so
bored and you're like I need to go
create I need to produce I need to like
and then I just realize I am not built
and Men or you know all people but I
could always be from a man's perspective
we are not built to sit idle we are you
know created to work I don't think we're
actually creating to work 100 hours a
week but I think we are created to work
like 30 hours a week and like that's the
minimum where it's like you just have to
produce and you have to contribute
otherwise you feel pointless and I think
you die sooner
I mean human but also I mean like I I
only know my I only know like what men
are like because I'm a man you know
that's what I mean uh so yeah sure all
humans I'm sure are like that I just
haven't had this conversation with a lot
of people uh but I think that when you
retire like I've got family and they're
like I'm gonna retire I'm like I don't
think you should retire I just think you
should work a little bit less or do a
six month vacation because I think the
sooner you retire that's just you're
just like you just actually taken off
four years on your life do you know what
I mean like if you're gonna retire you
at least gotta go volunteer like you got
to contribute in some capacity you gotta
have something that you're living for
yeah yeah totally uh my I wouldn't take
a sabbatical uh I would I would just
pour my energy into a more creative
project that like is not the best
business use of time like I have a bunch
of ideas that I think could make a bunch
of money
and then I have a bunch of ideas I think
would be really fun to do that would
probably not make any money it might not
even get anybody to use it or like it or
maybe it'll turn out crappy but like I'm
intrigued to do it and so
um that's the temptation
all the things I want to do they all
cost money so I'm like [__] I need to
earn more yeah but you know what I mean
like in reality you don't
well it's only you know I guess
perception's reality who knows
perception right easier that you could
change reality so it's just change that
uh yeah I gotta run
um but yeah good episode all right
that's a pop
[Music]
foreign